mix
wes brown of doing
in the method of the man
berlinger bording crist
aspects and raidel on trellises
of the altar
in the annex directly
this extreme and hard
but to reduce stress
danger
resquín and bean and seeing what the
supervisor crashes from hunger
jazztel explosion wealth  it has de
jong un and you your soul
sound in the desert in the slade and the one to
serve not to desert
good afternoon everyone
thanks for being here
all I ask is
that I thank the subway for
finding my daughter
and the only thing I am asking is that
I need you to help me
find him to give himself up for his
love because my daughter's death
cannot remain like this I need the
police to help me please collaborate
with me so that  do it and so beautiful
so well
I need this not to stay so
continue looking
for my daughter's murderer
everyone help me please the police
please I ask you to please help
me find the murderer  but of my daughter this
cannot remain like this what happened right
now with leslie can continue to happen
with other other girls he can continue
doing the same in what can be
loose and they have to catch him
so that he can do justice I
need to do  justice I cannot
let this stay like this
I need please this is your sun
the blows on my murderers
and this is how they are going to look now if they walk like this
with a mask please I need the
help of the police to cooperate with me to
find the  killers of leslie
the spicy messages regarding the subject
ah
[Music]
if they
are good gloves form gross
as we were we can and linked
rose what mary ward are looking for out
I know why you stay work radio
happiness
and gloves on topics that I  you did it
what we want is that we help each other we
want to help the truth we are
delighted we don't want to go out anymore it's not
fair that yes he already did it once he is
going to do it again
think of your daughters sisters moms
yes, i did it once, it won't
do it again, we don't want that, we want justice,
the police already did their job, they
found her
, we thank them from the bottom of our hearts, now
we want them to continue doing their
job
and to put him behind bars
and the air
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
but not for this
the fighter becton trans
of himself
I don't know where
and
also from investigations egypt
link who says she is a single woman
but she is not the ex there is a little tone of the 1st she
is older than being old  center and
west point
a display raised before the vertigo
maybe you live alone suspects
learn
in the pits
i